[Musique]
avec jean martin aussant et jean luc
landry messieurs bonsoir bonsoir vous
avez entendu monsieur legault exprimé
une certaine ouverture quand même à ce
projet de stade au centre-ville et de
près par de nabeul et de soutien
financier si ça peut être rentable jean
pensé quoi jean martin aussant d'avoir
mais d'abord moi je suis transparent je
dois dire que je souhaite le retour des
expos à montréal j'aime beaucoup le buzz
là je pense que je vous ai déjà vu au
stade aussi c'est ceci dit dans le
contexte actuel on sort d'une des pires
crises de mémoire d'homme et les groupes
communautaires qui ont besoin d'être les
hôpitaux les 6h et celle des les écoles
laissez-passer pas sophisme de le dire
il ya peut-être des priorités plus
urgentes que de financer une équipe de
sport professionnel
donc j'espère moi personnellement que le
secteur privé va mettre l'argent qu'il
faut pour que le baseball reviennent à
montréal parce que je m'ennuie mais
actuellement politiquement ce serait
difficile je pense de défendre des fonds
publics pour tel projet vous en
pensez-quoi jean-luc j'avais trois
conditions de vent faut dire je suis pas
novateur de baise-moi mais je suis
d'accord pour pour la subvention mais
j'avais trois conditions la première
lancée afin que le confirmer faut pas se
faire penser un autre sens vidéotron
comme à québec
alors donc on fait quoi un
investissement dans l'espoir d'avoir un
club il faut qu'il soit confirmé
la deuxième affaire à ce que monsieur
legault vient dire sur les allemands la
tient pas la route là on ne peut pas
monsieur leubou ce qu'il dit c'est que
on peut subventionner les entreprises en
notant qu'elle crée des emplois qui vont
générer des impôts
ça c'est un raisonnement qui va
s'appliquer à tous les investissements
au québec
ça veut dire que le gouvernement devra
s'engager à se vend ses lectures m'ont
tous ceux qui font un investissement qui
créent de l'emploi
on pourrait avoir droit à une subvention
et donc sa peau de mon ca ça m'amène
dans mon troisième point la subvention
la plus basse possible
en autant que ça s'insère dans le
bouquet de d'autre que montréal mighty
pour les montréalais et les touristes et
105 rue s'intégrer dans le système
à
avec le grand prix avec le centre des
congrès avec nos musées et pour ça
s'apprend très attrayant alors si on
veut avoir des touristes qui vient ici
dépenser serons-nous qu' on est
suffisamment attrayant ça ça veut dire
de tout mettre l'argent dans un stade
plus on allait chez nous après plus rien
faire donc
parce que il n'est pas clair là qu'on va
tirer des tonnes de touristes avec une
équipe de baseball
la très grande majorité des gens qui se
présentent au baseball les gens de
montréal des gens du québec
essentiellement et jean marie pernot
genesis site web c'est un problème quand
on calcule et le ton biz économique ont
fait un grand total mais qu'on considère
pas qu'il ya du cannibalisme a fait
cannibalisation plus trop entre par
exemple les gens qui vont aller au
base-ball devons au moins aller au
cinéma ou au théâtre
donc si c'est juste un transfert du
budget de loisirs d'été des montréalais
et des québécois en général c'est pas
des retombées net il faut calculer
l'argent neuf qui vient d'ailleurs si on
prend dix excusez moi allez-y jean marty
jean matin si pire que ça
pour la raison suivante le québec
dépensent trop haut savoir si un pays
dépense trop ou une communauté dépense
trop il faut garder sa balance des
paiements le québec un déficit chronique
de sa maintenance dpm
ça veut dire qu'on dépense tout le temps
trop on n'a pas besoin de stimuler
l'économie au québec elle est déjà au
rouge stimuler mais de toute façon ce
projet ce vol est ce que c'est pour
stimuler l'économie ou six pour
engendrer des rentrées fiscales
supplémentaires du point de vue du
gouvernement jean martin vient de le
dire le net se passe rien que ça par
contre si on peut améliorer notre offre
globale pour montréal il ya des
avantages à le faire à montre encore une
fois ça doit s'intégrer dans une
stratégie globale
ok demi équipe quand même là pour
l'instant on aurait une quarantaine de
matches et pas 80 matchs ça fait partie
aussi de l'équation ça je pense dans la
réflexion je vous emmène donc pas très
loin de ce que vous disiez jean-luc
qu'on va parler un petit peu de des
attentes envers le budget girac sera
présenté jeudi on aura un budget à
ottawa le 19 avril n'est ce pas
merveilleux on en date jean martin pour
le budget fédéral n'est pas trop tôt non
c'était pas trop tôt et a fait
je sais pas si les attentes sont élevées
pour l'évolution parle du budget du
québec
oui par contre la semaine dernière cité
malraux au pré cité churchill cette
semaine dont on disait qu'il faut jamais
gaspillé une bonne crise et je pense que
c'est l'occasion d'avoir un budget qui
va peut-être en étonner plusieurs mais
qui va vraiment faire un virage clair
dans certaines certaines entreprises
innovantes dans les énergies vertes dans
les emplois d'avenir
ceci sur le plan général on souhaite
surtout budget sur le plan spécifique
moi j'en aurais eu la tempête
j'aimerais que le gouvernement donne une
bonne part à la prière collective
ce qu'on appelle parfois l'économie
sociale l'eau quelques mauvaises price
ou mauvaise perception des gens mais qui
a au québec seulement
c'est plus de dix mille entreprises
200000 emplois et ses 50 milliards de
notre pib
donc j'aimerais bien que le gouvernement
fasse une bonne part dans son budget ces
entreprises là qui à travers les crises
permettre au québec de mieux s'en sortir
qu'ailleurs et quand on regarde le coût
par emploi d à procréer en fait par des
fonds publics c'est qu'autant de 100 et
200 mille dollars pour une appropriée en
général les subventions en
entrepreneuriat collectif c'est coûte à
peu près 3 à 4000 dollars
donc chacun peut créer coûte beaucoup
moins cher et de sites d'entreprises en
plus ont un taux de survie supérieur aux
autres types d'entreprises dont qu'est
vraiment le filon kehl québec possède
plus que partout ailleurs au monde
il faudrait en profiter ok jean-luc
c'est quoi vos attentes pour le budget
girard ils sont déjà on l'a on a passé
dans la presse comme suit le politiques
publiques de l'asdeq d'instruments
depuis les économistes du québec voilà
et a55 chose qu'ont suggéré jaune
habitudes les plus importants pour moi
oui
la première c'est le retour à
l'équilibré budgétaire est ce aussi
faisable
surprenant notre minuscule à lille
le fait que c'est difficile qui ont des
sites chronique au québec mais c'est pas
tout à fait le cas alors on peut revenir
à l'équilibré budgétaire dans les cinq
prochaines saisons vous d'accord avant
d'aller à votre autre point jean martin
que vous d'accord avec cinq ans pour le
déficit zéro moi je pense qu'il défie 7
0 il faut lui visé quand il sera pas
trop douloureux pour les populations les
plus vulnérables et dans la loi
d'ailleurs le plus sévère qu'on avait là
dessus il y avait toujours place à une
exception attend crise si on n'est pas
en temps de crise là je me demande
qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'une crise
donc on devrait pas aller à 7 ans
jean-luc attendre un petit peu pour le
déficit zéro moi de mes calculs montrent
que ce n'est pas nécessaire en notant
qu' on parle du déficit avant le
versements au fonds des générations
ah oui dans après une crise comme celle
là on n'a pas besoin d'aller reverser de
l'argent dans le fonds des générations
alors donc je parle d'un équilibre
budgétaire avant que ces versements ça
difficile donc on parle à peu près 15
milliards en ce moment le vrai déficit
ces 12 milliards avant versements au
fonds des générations
et là dedans il ya une provision non
vers hp quel point on ne les utilisez
votre deuxième point jean luc c'est à
quoi vous oui vous vous souvenez la
semaine dernière on a parlé de la
provision 4 milliards moody's avait mis
de côté alors le deuxième set pas se
lancer dans les gros seins dépenses
d'infrastructures on a un énorme déficit
d'entretien de nos infrastructures
encore alors c'est pas le temps de
partir dans des nouveaux projets quand
notre système en ce moment est en train
de se détériorer
c'est à papa comme si vous faites un
allonger votre maison pendant que le
toit beaucoup lié probablement l'hiver
prochain alors commençons par entretenir
nos infrastructures et on verra plus
tard pour les nouveaux investissements
dernier point le gouvernement le goût
mise beaucoup sur l'accroissement des
transferts fédéraux en santé
jean martin ce criminel girard doit
inclure des montants hypothétique de la
sorte dans ses prévisions
dans son budget il ya toujours une part
des prothèses dans un budget notamment
la gr croissance économique qu'on y
mette ça peut être plus ou moins ce qu
est ce qu on s'attend à voir comme
croissance mais sur le plan de transfert
fait des roues qui contrôlent pas moi je
dirais pas trop généreusement l'état
parce qu'on risque fort d'être déçus
jean-luc un mot mais il ne va pas y en
aura pas de transfert fédéral pour la
santé dans les prochaines années
continues tu pourrais alors il faut pas
compter dessus
ok certainement pas ok jean luc jean
martin on surveille de toute façon le
budget je dis merci à vous deux bateaux
et des pouvoirs nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh